it's also Mother's Day this Sunday so we
want to celebrate mamas
Mary do your do your kids celebrate with
you do y'all do anything special they do
but I'm a grandmother now so part of
what I'm celebrating is my daughter Lily
who's just an amazing mother herself and
um yeah it's like the whole any excuse
for our whole gang to just Pile in dogs
kids babies everybody it's wonderful
that is wonderful especially as a
grandma now yeah I I love
being a grandmother it's so boring to
say but it is the greatest
I know it's special it's different we
text each other uh grandmother photos
all the time it's so it must be so odd
to I have a six and eight-year-old but I
can't so obviously I can't imagine but
like to have your kids be mothers you
know what I'm saying like that's that's
interesting that Dynamic like being like
wait you're a mom too that's just weird
I can't look at my eight-year-old and go
I hope you do well like I hope I did
well enough um what about y'all what do
you do leave me out you're like I don't
know I'm just gonna sit here I'm
enjoying it okay I like this and I'm
glad I have this is
can't share it with you everyone
but I'm not a drink up right now
[Applause]
[Music]